crime on the las vegas strip has gone
up as southern nevada tries to recover
from the pandemic
metro police say they want to show just
what they're doing to address the issue
and they gave access only to the i-team
for an
undercover operation to target sex
trafficking
specifically by arresting pimps who are
forcing women to sell sex
vanessa murphy has this exclusive report
you'll only see here
this is memorial day weekend and while
visitors enjoy the las vegas strip
there are a lot of criminals and a lot
of
and there's a lot of nefarious activity
going down on the strip jim where you
going
this team at metro police headquarters
we have a mission
it's ready to address a dark underbelly
of the glitz and glam
welcome everybody to i think what's
going to be the largest
human actual human trafficking operation
we've ever done lieutenant william macho
heads the vice section
we're here tonight because memorial day
weekend attracts
a great deal of traffickers to the
valley arrest reports obtained by the
i-team point to a rise in violent and
prostitution related crimes on las vegas
boulevard
sex traffickers seize that opportunity
to come in and sell
people machico tells the i-team busy
weekends with holidays or special events
attract pimps bringing in prostitutes
across state lines
especially from california metro is
teaming up with federal agencies to
target the pimps
police will work both in uniform and
undercover i'll just be walking through
the casino
floor and wait for pimps to come up and
approach me
this officer will be posing as a
prostitute they usually start out by
complimenting us telling us asking us
what we're doing out there
they go on to just tell us how we can do
better and how they can help us
but what she describes is a broken
promise
they go after children they go after
vulnerable women
they're just extremely violent people
they enslave them in 2020 metro
identified
128 adult victims of sex trafficking
meaning they were forced or coerced to
sell sex
the department also identified 123
victims
under the age of 18. in this eight-year
study of child
sex trafficking in las vegas 922
child victims were identified we have
some of the highest numbers of
recoveries
in in the nation
every single year and that included last
year during kovid
which is actually surprising as well
because
you would think with the shutdown of
tourism prostitution
and sex trafficking would slow down but
it did not
and he says sex trafficking is connected
to other crime
theft against people buying sex also
known as trick rolls
pimp turf wars and according to metro
about
half of the alleged pimps arrested are
linked to gangs
it's just another challenge with being a
major tourist destination
this vehicle can help us out on our
undercover operations
on this saturday night there's a command
post cameras show different angles and
several teams are at work while the eye
team is embedded
they can plan the entire response from
this vehicle
a total of 14 arrests are reported
lieutenant matchko says
three are suspected pimps in one case
metro police say a suspect told an
officer posing as a prostitute
he wanted half of her earnings
threatened to choke her and became
territorial with another pimp if i can
go out there and make that arrest and
put them in prison and prevent them
from doing this to an actual victim then
at the end of the day i've done my job
and her work continues the i-team has
learned police are maintaining contact
with four others who continue to reach
out to
undercover detectives to try to recruit
them
into prostitution vanessa murphy 8 news